teller yeah they do would come in so
much great thanks play but yeah so we
all were meeting out last night the
maluma concert and basically I haven't
seen a reaction since Jerome Jarre with
this guy right here everyone wearing a
selfie in the audience in the crowd like
he couldn't leave off I haven't
literally when you got a pretty face you
know life is life is life like when you
got it like that it's that's the way
that's cool ya know it's not the worst
thing that ever happened here's all this
attention and one thing they want to
talk about there's no but I have a ton
of times what do you do with that how to
build his personal brand what he has so
much going you work backwards the key is
to figure out like where you are at this
point in your life like what you work
backwards from what you want like
everything I do is about buying the New
York Jets professionally and like it
really helps when you know what you want
so to your point like when you have that
much attention it's such a big deal when
you actually know what you want to
happen whether that's a TV show starting
your own media company starting a
fashion brand putting yourself in a
position to get brands to endorse you
make 15 million dollars a year marry
someone like it actually doesn't matter
it could be anything start it you know
it could literally be anything but what
I would tell your brother is like if you
have a set and by the way it changes
right we're all different than we were
three years ago and it's gonna change in
three years but to the best of your
ability based on all your life and all
the crew you know I know enough to know
like right now what is it what's the
chip on the shoulder and what's the
ambition and you balance those and then
you really can figure it out yeah yeah
yeah so it's like working back is from
working back from where you started what
do you want to happen if I was like yo I
can make that happen
the question is what would you want to
do if you could control like
professionally did I name a bunch of
things you can't because that will help
ya because I'm like very much like you
in a sense I guess the other graph is a
wine guy yep I started
that's right then you jumped and jumped
and jumped yep John and I went from like
my jumps to like dancer choreographer
creative director actor Fitness social
media branding yep these kind of things
writing producing and it's like so for
me is I guess when you look at creative
success creative sits in the center of
that for you yeah
creative right clearly which is which is
super common for somebody cradle yeah
I'm all over the place just had enough
of not being one place that I was able
to build something but like I have
empathy for that yeah but for a brand to
go
oh yeah he's great for this because he
lines with us because he does this
they're like oh no he's God what does he
do he does things which is good for me
when I I don't know like it could be
anything from like acting something I
can I can do a million different things
you know but uh but it's hard working
with brands because do you want to work
with brands yeah I do I but not on like
I was founded not on like I don't I
don't I've never done I probably never
will do like a one-off post say yeah I
want it like create like companies with
them like I want to like invest time and
bigger because the people that follow me
I choose to push follow and choose to
push on their notifications and choose
to comment and like and and write my D
and and ask me questions and really get
involved with who I am and what I do
whatever that may be you want to respect
this you don't want to just sell out
[ __ ] I get it I get it completed
precept and twenty grand preach it up
you're preaching right I believe in it
so much I've never done one branded post
to either ever and I've been on for some
crazy-ass yeah yeah to like you know we
were talking about a lot of influencers
have a certain audience I think his
audience is very valuable because he's
not just an influencer ad it's not just
about how many people follow him it's
you know when you're playing a concert
to who middle-aged women I mean my mom
we were at a
as influencers she's a hoarder of course
I get it and yeah those people are
making purchase decisions the other
thing I think is great is the bow will
go out and meet those people if he's
with somebody from bran and you know
they have the renter that he'll be like
hey I'm with this person and he's not
like hey how much you gonna pay me for
this it's like he's creating
relationships I think that's something
different that a lot of people aren't
doing you know I'd rather have a long
time but also it's like does it hurt me
to to post anything on anybody you know
I mean does it hurt if your friends like
hey can you post this on your
surrounding like yeah I don't care it's
24 hours what I would it helps in you
know I mean it doesn't hurt me and it
brings attention that person which helps
them and if I can help someone I can
what it's like when we were out there
the south by stop questioning my kind of
pops you know I mean the guy was like I
know who you are because my
sister-in-law is a huge fan shut-ins a
dance to be in Chicago it's a big studio
and I was like FaceTime I was like
listen let's say hi you know at me so we
FaceTime it she'd pick up so we did a
video and I was like hey thanks fellas
for you know out here I'm whatever but
it's just what does it hurt doesn't hurt
me and it's a harmless practical yeah
even just a little present
that's your preaching yeah yeah you guys
are really similar like that the other
thing is he said that he likes to talk
about grants he likes whether he's
working with him or not
which is smarter like his studio he
could wear any shoe he wants doesn't
have to be case waste like that's the
type of stuff but yeah you could be into
because like some things he works but
there's some things he doesn't have do
you have all the words I get it of all
the things that you um are doing would
there be something that if like if you
had a pick one or you've done like
you've probably done this is me guessing
you've accomplished more in the dance
sphere than you have in the acting
sphere for yourself yeah do you still
have a lot of um for the acting spirit
oh that like if that would be your prep
anything what being like it not even a
TV star movie sir like on the soap I
think that's I think that's right so I'm
glad you said that
so that to me is how this goes like if
we had all day that's where this goes
now you start thinking about see that's
where I start thinking about who do you
do pieces of content with
how how do we get it in front of whom
and what absolutely like like you know
there's so many ways to do it like
getting getting pieces of content in
front of the right people you have a
very interesting dynamic because you
have so much awareness in the
marketplace because you were in such a
white heat moment that of a certain age
group like everybody in Hollywood
probably if they're over 32 highly
likely they know of you and have some
sort of thing so advantages and
disadvantages of secret 100% so I think
the way to me is like how do you
penetrate your content knowing that
instead of hoping it didn't exist right
right right
you know to me that's how you win you
win when you're when you accept it as a
positive or negative just neutral yeah
some people lose their mind some people
like [ __ ] that guy like you know how it
is yeah I'm super beautiful about it you
know I mean if I can stay away from it I
do because sure came with so much
baggage yeah yeah it's no need to bring
right now but well yeah sometimes it's
like oh not gonna get this just because
he had you know I mean it's like so it
or just relationship friends and he have
things like that you know definitely it
definitely played in the music business
you know I mean with like creative
direction and starting artists and
labels and stuff that I was working with
far before and then it just changed
after you know I mean because
introductions I made to that person of
course I mean then they established and
it just hurt so of course it's uh you
know it's one of those K because I just
I was life yeah and you move on you keep
blowing and you brand how old are you
about to be 31 next week I mean you
literally fundamentally have your entire
life be funny yeah it's just crazy right
you like live the life you know no no
I'm very I mean that's it
Network nothing but I bought a house of
26 I'm very proud of that
it was like more of it where'd you grow
out of him and I'm Anaheim yeah you're
an Angels fan I am
yeah that's awesome yeah
how old were you in that World Series
with them what the month rally monkey
you're young
do you remember it or no is that even
too young for you angels versus Giants
World Series yeah 31 you just weren't
into it then right cuz it's not what a
baseball game with my stepdad oh yeah in
love at the time but I love the game
even but I didn't I guess I got at the
time you realize what he did yeah he was
a dick and he was rough and you know
he's better at helping someone says my
sister's yeah I mean and but as I got
older I'm like be hateful bracing my
mouth you put food over my mouth
roof over my head clothes on my back and
these things that we couldn't afford
that's right you know so he really took
care of now like I'm right yeah whatever
you need bro what's cool I got you
that's cool so yeah I just what do you
think well they've got I feel like you
you know you have so much context for
both you you have the most context for
both of us for whatever reason I you
know there's a lot of people we could
work with but bow is somebody that I
feel like he's a superstar he's gonna be
a superstar he is already what just feel
like there's more depth there yeah
there's up and there's talent which has
longevity yes and not only that but also
his you mean when this pretty face goes
away in 30 years it's still just gonna
be it'll be distinguished face and you
know and he's real about it yeah and I
mean I think you know there's everybody
I think we were talking about like when
you were called like the wine guy oh
this guy's gonna try to do Twitter oh
now it's doing Twitter and how he's
gonna try to do this and it's kind of
like that it would be more like oh well
he did this so that's what he is and I'm
like no you know I wouldn't we wouldn't
be interested in doing stuff with him if
I didn't one liked him as a person to
think he has longevity in the space so I
like I told I was sitting next to this
guy on the plane and there's the two
scripts on the phone on the floor and I
literally literally why in his first
laughing yeah yep three scripts on it on
lay down seats and steps and I was like
you gotta read all those just on this
fight yeah and he was like at least two
unlike good luck and then that's it you
know I mean and then he was like what do
you do and I was like yeah and he's like
oh nice and kind of like brushed it off
and he's like who you with I was like
entire he goes oh great
so like just having that in my pocket
it's like yeah yeah I'm totally gonna
chase inside he must be fun
mm-hmm any person can you know what if I
was with Jill blow your preach I mean
he's idea who's that boy he goes oh nice
yeah good luck yeah so right it's a
trade it's a trade it's a trade there's
this new space for like a marketing
director or somebody that basically
doesn't compete with your manager that's
when you're trying to fill right and
people like him zooming into us to do
that I mean you know I think a lot of
people are gonna want to fall on your
footsteps right even big you know
celebrities you would think you know or
have also your swimming event and they
don't they don't or like the the agents
are not showing them the right stuff for
this lab I'm totally I totally get it
and said you know what if you want
somebody to have on your website you
call them phone and call them and say
hey I think you've Bradford that's
basically what we're doing now yeah with
celebrities and the ones that are humble
enough to say okay
I don't have to deal with so-and-so if
Gary doesn't give me a deal with why am
i meeting with him
and I'm like I see it all the time and
Hollywood I'm like people are really
gonna drop the ball when they fees
called entitlements yeah and when you
don't come from a whole lot you know you
if you could stay grounded and you don't
want to rewrite history
you can stay real humble real fast use
the advantage I feel like we keep it as
certain percent of entitlement you want
you want you want you want to be
thoughtful right I don't think it's I
think entitlement is you think you
deserve it and I think what you're
talking about where you're about to go
and I've already got a sense of your
energy is look you need to be thoughtful
yeah like I put a few things that are in
the detriment of me long-term it's not
that like you know it's but I definitely
that's right yeah like everyone like if
you call me I think the acting thing is
interesting to me I don't have the
necessarily answer what I like is that's
what you want which leads me to like
more like so I think there's gonna be a
really interesting genre within Facebook
of people making original films and
uploading to Facebook like so to me I
think you can control your success
potentially in the next half decade
without UTA WME managers I think that
there's a real opportunity and I think
it's gonna come in the form of
independent films on Facebook that pop
so it's funny to say that right because
Britney and she did that thing in which
the interview is she goes she looks on
getting a sense that she was so if
you've got a big opportunity with
Facebook that wouldn't do it for you and
I was like it makes sense I think it's
this way I don't think that does it for
you either
I think use the leverage of that success
to get you the thing you know jumping
right right that makes sense is you know
it's crazy just you know she'll cut yeah
absolutely because it's seven stone
people see you and it's just level
if you asked me to predict it if you
said if you said it predict how I become
a star it's something like that leads to
the other thing and then you realize oh
[ __ ] I got to go back to the other thing
right Will Smith's already doing it it's
great he's got to cuz he's cause as a
movie star he's not relevant and now
he's in the world there you go and then
the whole thing with Mark yesterday's I
didn't say what's that like there are
there an ultra and Mark Anthony they
were on a boat together and Mark would
teach them how to salsa dance dominant
viral this is right it went of course
it's like a horse and every time he goes
probably like man when you have that
kind of leverage yeah yeah that's that's
crazy so no Peterburg yes all right so I
did this thing for plant stories that we
talked to that I'm trying to get prints
in here for you I got me try to help you
get like a few artists in here just
because it'll be quicker I got my speed
down yeah I connected it in the artist
space and voices like my little brother
so he faced our last week I was like hey
can you help me like I'm pushing his
song and just do a video to it and then
I'll repost it he's like I just want
like good content that's very cool so we
just shot it right before we came and
and I posted it and Peter Berg will be
one DM and I mean we follow each other
because I box and I fight and stuff and
and he was like yo I really love the
content you've been doing it he's like
it's really good and I gotta thanks man
how culture blah blah blah blah you know
but just for him to just go out of his
way and be like because even though
they're little little snacks
oh yeah maddening I really think you
know I couldn't agree with that more
yeah I can you only believe that that's
what you should be doing yeah I just
died edit carried away with and what you
don't want to do is like corny I know
[ __ ] I know it goes - I know you
don't want to you don't want to make
King batch content cuz that's King
batches world
and matches the mess no he's the best I
understand what you're thinking yeah not
that that's wrong right yeah that's how
batches gonna get put on yeah I totally
get it and listen listen I have started
spending a lot of time with the rock and
like like and by the way the rock Will
Smith that's exactly we're talking about
that right like yeah but just I will
tell you that uh if you asked me because
of the way you popped on to the
consciousness
I don't trust Hollywood I'd rather you
go to the consumer and then put pressure
on them yeah it's your Wayne you had
love you have a funny version of how I
think about John Travolta John Travolta
became this massive star and then
Hollywood said no yeah and he had to get
lucky that a ridiculous character like
Quentin Tarantino put him in a movie
like Pulp Fiction and then it popped but
had that not happened the Machine said
no it is I know nothing about the
Machine like that I just know humans
there's an enormous percent of the
machine that looks even says no I know
what you are period and all it takes is
one person and there's always one person
and that got it so for me you don't need
to make comedy skits with bootie girls
you can make a meaningful 1 minute piece
of cut you want to be an action star
make a one-minute [ __ ] action star
video alright see what happens yeah take
it down there like like what what yeah
get some young kid that's [ __ ] at NYU
is gonna be the next [ __ ] Spielberg
you catch him right go [ __ ] jump out
of a bridge or no time the [ __ ] you're
doing somebody made a piece who was that
kid that showed me I don't know who was
with me some kid showed me a piece of
content where he like came out of the
Instagram oh yeah yeah you've seen some
of this [ __ ] right he's huge
right because [ __ ] is fire he's like I
don't know do that [ __ ] like pop that
I've been doing like I don't know how to
do it either but so can we do something
why are you [ __ ] mailing everything
in cuz I'm gonna make some
Kelly makes it why are you late bro are
you so lazy bad can I go first oh my god
anyway nonetheless you see where I'm
going yeah I think here's what I would
say you're in control of your content
just cuz skits pop like me when I came
out the gate
I made 22-minute wine videos on YouTube
yeah the only thing on YouTube was
[ __ ] pirated content people won't
even make an original content yeah was
all [ __ ] it was all Simpsons clips
and SNL and like people just like like
not knowing what took like you must be
like this Pat like people don't know
what that you know and I was always told
like this won't work it's short form
people forget this conversation back in
Oh Santa can't make long-form video like
you could make a in theory you could
make a 10 minute video help remind me
babban on Instagram so you could post 7
one-minute videos yeah you could but no
one likes this way
I totally greats why I don't do any of
that content but let me see this nobody
likes to watch 22 minute videos on
YouTube if that first minute of that
video is fire and it looks like a motion
picture and you figured out how to make
the 58 59 and 60 a second for real right
then you want to well that's like the
cop series with DeStorm so yes I know so
to me I know Dave snorum I don't know
the series here's what I would say yeah
nobody's stopping you
yeah if I were you it's like cooler like
now homies for life and live together in
this studio apartment the first really
thing the first video I would make is
straight-to-video face and be like I
want to make a 10 minute movie on
Instagram 10 carousel 1 minute videos
I'm the actor I need a production
partner who's the best DME with a link
to why you then I would [ __ ] him to sit
[ __ ] watch 3500 videos emails RIT
whatever pick somebody and [ __ ] make
it yeah you know the good thing about
that unfortunately well two things is
one I can just call friends and
actually like gotcha directors gotcha
and the second thing is like I can
actually afford what you just pay people
they're just a song no no no brother
you're exactly right so [ __ ] do that
and make a [ __ ] make a movie and yeah
like a time of the moon'll are crazy
like even the artists like French call
me he's like I'm really seeing this song
called famous and the word that I hope
you don't get famous I'm like influencer
who this would be great for a short
content on Instagram like you know these
guys they want people to make content
for them on Instagram like you could be
doing it for every artist it comes out
with a new song but here's my fail yeah
he'd beat me to it
that's not what he wants to like win
Sophia he wants something he wants to
make he wants me on that billboard in
starring in transformers 11 or he-man 1
or [ __ ] the fast and the fast and
[ __ ] that and that's amazing that 100
but I think what he doesn't realize the
white space yeah and I'm listening is
make an 11 minute movie on YouTube make
it look like a [ __ ] 11 minute movie
if you got peeps like that and [ __ ]
go yeah I don't know what to tell you
King made himself a comedy entity by
making comedy where people pay attention
make it 11 if you think you don't listen
I don't know well enough but I have a
feeling you can make an 11 minute action
scene for six minutes scene yes and I'm
empathetic to like blowing up buildings
I get it but like don't do that do what
you can and just make them and just
[ __ ] make them like get everybody in
the same way that Will Smith is in
essence doing something very similar to
what I do he's just a much bigger star
and it's going to work be he was the one
of the first to really go you know the
rock and Kevin Hart have been playing
Instagram smartly but will took it one
step even further because he had the
humility to do it I'm totally
would never he has the humility that was
its you got anything to prove to himself
and when you're in that car you be
playing French a song but honestly
honestly it doesn't matter all that
other [ __ ] he can do on the third post
you don't even you don't mix you don't
mix the two just make a fire seven
minute 13 second [ __ ] drama video and
just nobody stopping you
you're literally 1 7 minute 13 second
this person saved the world video away
from having everything you want okay you
do understand how right yeah that's real
though yeah and like the second you
realize you can play outside the
Hollywood Machine and you can force it
that's when everything changes I think
I'm genuinely gonna be one of the most
influential people in this country and
I'm never gonna play within the
framework of the game yeah you gonna
have to nor do you yeah go find those
talented people go find three other
actors and set up a [ __ ] seven
minutes 16 seconds ideo that's [ __ ]
playing on Facebook and YouTube and use
your one-minute video on Instagram to
push it and then do and then break the
wall make one video where you're like if
I were you based on everything I know
now I'd be like listen guys look this is
really important to me and I want to do
it in a different way so I just made it
and it's you know if you ever do if I've
ever brought you any value
just watch the entire seven sixteen and
like tell one friend about it break the
wall yeah and then now you've got an
entire audience it's gonna care and
hopefully it's fire yeah and then it's
sitting across you know there's some
[ __ ] assistant at WME forget about
your relationships a different person
who doesn't know you who's watching and
be like [ __ ] you still dope he's got
skills holy [ __ ] he looks exactly like
the person I pictured that we need for
the supporting role in this blockbuster
right yeah yeah that's it yeah so now I
have to now have it just know
getting flowy good one that maybe we
could I don't know the acting one is
saying you said you found your world but
so the reason I started doing like dance
just living dance videos little comedy
hands here and there on the instagrams
cuz everyone loves me
yeah and I'm like everyone already knows
that I'll never do dance shop but I'll
put up and ya know 45 seconds or
something that people can enjoy with
something funny
backing it and within that you know and
the other stuff I've been doing and
being consistent with it with the
content cuz I got a game like three
hundred fifty four hundred thousand
dollars in the past year just don't
really collab with anybody just do my
own thing and just being quality right
you're good at what you do
right so I decided I want to do a dance
workout DVD app yep what if I'm saying
all so I did like a crazy transformation
of like body like stupid and I was just
took everyone on that journey
I'm still on somebody's whose body got
transformed minded yours yeah you got
tight yeah yeah I say and give it
quickly you know I mean that thing I was
out of shape but I mean when you have
muscles underneath [ __ ] can happen fast
yeah
I'm even learning that I got a little
bit of muscles I'm like whoa three good
days like it's crazy like I've always
heard I mean it's the thing is in those
morning it's everything but it but it
but if you don't have the muscles
already developed
that's right Valley one takes a little
bit longer karate bunch of sports so so
that was easier for me but with thing is
I took people on this journey Jesus
Christ [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna be how long was that two and a
half three months yeah man that's [ __ ]
awesome
you were you were like Ian before then
yeah yeah I'm literally right mix in
this run it seems more like why I wear
[ __ ] sweaters and t-shirts and
jackets totally what I mean I'm not on
camera I mean 100% like acting
not one hacking job have I and I've done
a lot of stuff like Rayleigh overnight
we're the same manager like our personal
manager like I know like I have a lot on
my really in shape right now yeah who
said Jesus Christ I love it isn't shape
huh
some real [ __ ] six-pack that's not
even like [ __ ] [ __ ] around that
like a big heavy yeah yeah exactly right
this is not a pretend six-pack yeah like
I'm like which one which of your
pictures do the best engagement on my
shirt yeah man I want to find like I'll
have like you know Jesse tomorrow my
chance no he's actually directing and
producing and writing the whole nicky
jam story dude you need to make [ __ ]
seven minute scene you basically listen
to me you need you want to be a movie
star yeah be a movie star on YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram yeah make the
content be in full control every story
you've ever dreamed up because it will
work
yeah tell you right now with it you can
deliver one line in one video and the
right person is gonna see it and it will
change your career and with it you know
how this works
yeah the way you gotta be like what did
she do it's one moment in time but she
grew up in a game that was there was
people that had to say it yeah we're all
not growing up in a game where they the
audience gets to say enough you know to
get lucky that somebody said yeah you
right you get to dance in the background
of this that game yourself listen about
that people can see whether just make it
they say yes just [ __ ] make the scene
of a cop like just do it
just be a bad boy bad boys 3 you and
[ __ ] somebody I like just do it
yeah like actually that's where you can
even instill some of your normal your
your actual sense of humor you can make
one that just looks like the scene you
can do it all you can make one for a
week or two that's a scene of an action
movie and show the 9 minutes of that
clips there and then the following week
you just make a spoof and make pretend
that you're starring in Jumanji - yeah
do you know what I mean you could
absolutely Jesse like literally my point
of recommendation is you're putting
acting on a pedestal that's higher than
the thing that you like what I just
watched with you and like that's um
that's incredibly good content yeah it's
just high quality done well and the kind
of [ __ ] you would see like on screen or
television or on a phone yeah I think
you should just do that literally ASAP
what yeah with acting like literally I
think I should I got my dream as I go on
your account in three weeks cuz he pings
me or she pings me and I look and like
the videos you coming out and you're a
waiter and there's like it's a literally
I look I think I'm watching When Harry
Met Sally and like and then it says go
to this link to watch the whole seven
minutes and you just like literally just
did it yeah
you have enough scale of audience yeah
if Berg saw you in that environment that
would mean something different - it just
would brother I know I'm right about
this yeah just own it take it and to
your point between relationships and
finances
unlike 99% of people you can do it right
now it goes to it and it goes with the
whole but you said that's why notice how
I no no no no notice how I made the
process yeah if I could do anything
right so start with that in the system
you can we could always sell ten
thousand subscriptions to some that's
the booby prize yeah it's really hard to
be will or or the rock but see I think
that to like I think for me I go I go
yeah we could sell we can sell five 10
million copies that's 60 down cut at DVD
over there good I'm gonna just fund my
own [ __ ] movie yeah but but but but
but you're you're I'm telling you we do
it here now correct it's something you
11 years to build that thing yeah like
it doesn't happen like that you're not
posting you and your friends are not
posting buy the DVD you're selling 11
million copies right think it's a lot we
could make a couple million bucks even
but like you know what I mean yeah and
first of all it's not gonna be a CD that
games over right so it's gonna be an app
development real like it you know it is
that's why it hasn't happened yet right
whereas you now literally as you're
going down the elevator hitting up the
seventh best production people you know
having a meeting in 48 hours and
literally picking up like literally
filming in nine days somewhere yeah and
you're doing it all in spec you're
making your own film as the Gateway to
the next film yeah and it's not a movie
like all those song but you know I mean
brother it's not a movie like the kids
that all made that airplane movie yeah
it's not bad
ya know you see where I'm going right
yeah make a scene from something you'd
want to make yeah it's badass and it's
amazing fighting in action and you know
how to do all that [ __ ] yeah and you got
stunt people and people that can
choreograph it like [ __ ] do it I mean
I mean yeah and then we really I mean to
be very honest then you know just like
all this stuff goes viral right like
whether it's will or that dude that I
met LA that guy was doing the voice-over
sport [ __ ] where he's using like crass
Bob whatever you know I was like this
guy's [ __ ] an [ __ ] like he's doing
like do you see that guy yeah maybe
you're the one who now makes movie
content on Instagram yeah maybe you're
the first guy that like we're looking at
it as like is this a trailer like maybe
people confused even yeah maybe you make
a trailer right maybe that's what you're
making
one minute movie trailers and then you
get really creative because you just
make an up [ __ ] yeah so maybe the
biggest literally so that's what you got
it sure no good so get a [ __ ] writer
you know you're laughing cuz you know
where I'm about to go next literally I
think you could sell a movie to
Hollywood in a month because you made up
a trailer yeah and it's so fresh people
like what is that and literally you're
getting reach out to them be like we
wanna buy the rights that yeah I'm gonna
I could see you get it all right I'm
running super [ __ ] late will connect
soon
[Music]